Il est là !
Le puceau qui a cliqué sur la vidéo !
Bravo !
Voilà... C'est gratuit.
Aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on va faire?
Demain faut prendre ses résolutions pour 2017...
On va prendre la résolution pour 2017 d'être fort en dessin.
Et on va voir si ça a marché.
On sait d'avance que non,
Ça fait 3 ans qu'on s'exerce et on stagne
Maiiiis
Y'aura peut-être du progrès.
Avant de commencer à faire des oeuvres d'art qui valent très très cher
J'aimerais souligner le fait que
...
Je suis petit
Mon frère est grand
Je suis très nul en musique
Mon frère est fort en musique
Je suis très nul en dessin
Mon frère est fort en dessin
Lui il fait des trucs comme ça !
Comme ça là !
Il fait des gros hipsters en short, comment il fait?
Il fait... Comme ça là!
Non ça c'est un peu moyen.
Regardez la finesse du trait.
Le talent du talentueux Florent Hauchard
Et à côté son petit frère fait de la musique comme ça:
*Extrait de la vidéo "La leçon musicale"*
Dessine comme ça:
Regarde, regarde la rondelle, regarde la rondelle, elle est là, elle est là!
Et fait cette taille !
Putain !
C'est parti ! Si vous avez pas vu la première video, j'm'en bats les couilles
Vous chercherez ce que c'est !
Ah manque de respect total !
Ah bah avant la nouvelle année on peut faire de la merde !
Dessine un calendrier.
C'est simple c'est un rectangle , c'est un rectangle.
Et dans le rectangle.. Euh tu fais ça
Et ensuite y'a des colonnes comme ça
Hop.
Hop, ok , d'accord. [GOOGLE] : Oh, i know, is a calendar !
Voilà il a trouvé. C'est parfait ça ressemblait euh..
A.. à.. à.. à que des belles.. belles choses.
Sa m'stresse le son.
Dessine une boussole !
OK !
C'est un rond,
Avec dedans des aiguilles qui font ça genre.
Ok et ça s'tourne.
Et bah voilà il a trouvé !
Il a trouvé !
Pourtant, on aurait pu croire que c'était un œil !
Ou une bonne grosse chhh...
Non.
Non, non.
Dessine un ours.. en peluche.
J'vais l'faire à base de ronds, attends j'tente une nouvelle technique, c'est un nouveau mouvement d'art.
C'est un petit peu comme le cubisme etc...
Donc ça c'est ses mains.
ça c'est sa tête.
[GOOGLE] : I see yoga.
Il a vu du yoga le gars mais arrête de fumer !
ça, nan mec.
Je sais pas, je sais pas. Chais pas, chais pas !
Teddy Bear ! Ok, l'oreille, la deuxième oreille ! Le truc, le machin ! Hop !
ET NAN !
Et nan !
Une feuille !
Bon on va faire une feuille de cannabis mon gars.
Ah ça vous connaissez !
ça !
Entre ton heure de perm et ton heure de français t'en fume hein !
Connard !
C'est une feuille ça, c'est une feuille.
Mec je, je... Vous voyez je sais même pas dessiner une feuille de cannabis !
Je hein ça montre bien que c'est pas mon truc !
La drogue.
La guedro.
Mec c'est un truc de ouf ! Je vois à quoi ça ressemble mais dès que j'veux le dessiner,
J'fais d'la merde !
C'est quoi cette maladie !
Mais voila c'est ça ! C'est ça que j'ai fais mec !
Nan j'avoue c'est pas ça.
Mais c'est ça que j'avais en tête ! J'arrivais pas à...
Putain c'est incroyable.
ça me pète les couilles mon gars !
C'est une vraie maladie.
Un cercle.
Bon, mec...
[GOOGLE] : Oh, i know, it's a circle !
VOILAAA
P'tin, il a vu que j'étais nul.
Il a eu pitié mon gars !
Une piscine !
Ok ! Vue de haut !
Vue aérienne d'une piscine.
Vue au drone des D.J.I., tout ça.
Maintenant on connaît bien les drones.
Une piscine c'est ça ! Et dedans y a des vagues...
Comme ça.
[GOOGLE] : Oh, i know, it's a pool !
OH ELLE A RECONNU !
Mais Google !
Mais tu es le futur !
Alors du coup c'est quoi qu'il a pas...
Teddy Bear.
Comment les gens dessinent des Teddy Bears ?
Donc nous, il s'est dit que c'était peut-être une cacahuète
[Rire]
Ou une poire !
Ou.. un singe !
Ouais, non mais là j'avoue la première version était mieux quand même...
*musique dramatique*
NON. NON. Non. non.
Oh les mecs ! Ils font des p'tits... ça vaaa !
ça dessine bien, ça a appris à 2 ans parce que ça avait pas de console à dessiner HEIN !
ça lisait aussi des romans et des mangas, j'suppose hein !
Putin comment j'ai le seum !
Voilàà, oh attend le mec c'est cheaté il a fais une souris.
Oh lui d'accord, lui il a fait un truc vaudou !
Non mais OK.
Non mais je vois que Google il fais comme mes profs quand j'étais au lycée :
Il en favorise certains...
Nan mais c'est bien ! Tu reproduis bien le modèle social pourri dans lequel on est, bravo !
*clap clap*
Bon mec, on va mieux faire.
Un scorpion !
Très très simple !
Euuuh la queue, avec le p'tit pique...
Ok, ensuite une fois qu'y a la queue, là y a le corps, OK.
Ensuite là y a la tête et ensuite là y a une autre pince.
I see dolphin, the great wall of China.
Il voit la MURAILLE DE CHINE.
MAIS TU T'FOUS D'MA GUEULE !
Ah c'est bon ça c'est un scorpion, il a vu la muraille de Chine mon gars !
La muraille de Chine hyper agressive, avec des queues et des pinces mon gars !
Tu passes acheter ton pain, BLAH !
Une soucoupe volante !
Boah, ah mais là il nous mets bien !
Le dessin nul à chieeeer...
*RIRES*
Un micro-ondes, très très simple.
ça tous les soirs tu mets un poulet la dedans.
"Oh it's a microwave" ! p*tain je l'ai bien fait mec !
Franchement regarde !
Regarde la ressemblance, voilà le modèle sur lequel je me suis basé.
C'est un LG ! Regardez la ressemblance !
P*tain ! c'est incroyable les ingénieurs d'LG sont fiers de moi !
Un canon, très très simple.
J'allais beaucoup au cirque quand j'étais petit et je voyais la femme canon.
Qui était là.
Et ensuite y'avait des cheveux.
Et elle faisait "ouhouuuu je vole yeaaah" !
Et google ne reconnaît pas.
Un canon mais mec c'est ça.
[GOOGLE] : A skateboard.
Mais c'est un canon p*tain ! Mais qu'est-ce que tu veux que ce soit ça mon gars !
C'est un canon !
[GOOGLE] : I see potato.
Une potato.. Mais ta mère ! Ta mère...
Non, mais j'ai... C'est pareil, c'est comme t'aleur le truc du cannabis !
Je sais à quoi ça ressemble, j'arrive pas à le faire !
Mec, c'était... J'ai une maladie, j'ai une terrible maladie !
On va appeler des chercheurs.
Le Smiley Face.
[GOOGLE] : Oh, I know, it's smiley face!
Bah oui, mais oui, mais mec attends !
C'est facile... Niveau CE1 !
"Face", ah ! Juste un visage !
[GOOGLE] : I see line, crayon, nose.
Face. Smiley Face. Non, face tout court ! Face, Ah! Poker Face du coup.
C'est une FACE, c'est un mec qui sourit pas, c'est une face.
C'est, euh AAH, euuh. Une strawberry? Non, non. Un ours? Non, euh. Non, house plant.
Il a pété un câble, on a cassé Google !
Il a pris mon visage pour un gâteau d'anniversaire, pour du pain, et pour une fraise. Voilà.
Mais, non mais regarde, mec ! C'est scandaleux ! *Rires*
Tu reconnais ça et tu reconnais pas mon truc ?!
Mais mec, c'est scandaleux...
Mais mon gars... MAIS MEC ! Mais, WHAT ? *CRI* AAAHAHAHAHAHAHA
Mais mon gars... Attends, lui c'est un mangaka. Voilà, c'est un dessinateur Death Note qui a fait ça.
Alors, mon couteau ! Il est très bien. "Boomerang".
Oh, y'a un, oh j'avoue ça a aussi un petit mix entre le... la batte de baseball et le boomerang, mon gars.
RIGOLE ! Rigole...
Mais y'en a qui... Mais mec ! Non, mais le gars quoi ! C'est lui qui design les skins de Counter Strike... Des couteaux.
*Soupir* D'accord...
Donc, là t'as vu un couteau, mon gars ?... D'accord !
Moi, j'pense y'a eu des p'tits chèques... Qui ont été envoyés par à Google.. Mais OK !
Ok, suivant !
Euuh... Un écureuil ? Est-ce que si j'prends un modèle, genre, si j'm'inspire pendant 8 secondes d'un écureuil ?
*Murmures*
Ok, c'est bon !
*Musique épique*
[GOOGLE] : I see dog or battlecap.
*RIRES*
Mon gars... *RIRES CONTINUS*
Mec, ça m'énerve... J'ai envie d'pleurer...
Oh une vache mec, c'est juste des pattes et des mamelons...
[GOOGLE] : I see a rhinoceros.
Il a mis un rhinocéros *rires*
Euh... attends, vite... attends. *TRYHARD*
Les mamelons, les mamelons...
*rage* Mais putain ! Avec une souris de merde, tu peux rien faire !
*voix désespérée* Un nuage...
Ouah ! Ca, je m'en souvient ça...
Pas de soucis, alors les nuages...
ça, ça passe, c'est bien.
Ah ! Alors ça, y'a pas de problème hein pour les cassos...
Alors ! Comment les gens font des écureuils ? Explique-moi...
*rire*
J'avoue, c'est mieux... Je peux rien dire parce que dans tous les cas, c'est mieux...
Eh! Regardez les mecs ce qu'ils font eux, ils font juste une vieille queue, comme ça et...
Ouais... on peut pas parler...
Faut que je prenne du recul par rapport à ce que je fais là, je fais trop d'égo...
Un toaster ! Alors ça, c'est comme le micro-ondes, c'est tout pareil...
Ok, vous faites ça, là, vous mettez un tout petit peu de perspective...
Et vous faites une... une double tranche de grille-pain qui ressort. Voilà...
Ca marche, ça passe nickel...
On dirait aussi une enceinte portative sur laquelle tu as posé ton téléphone.
Mais... Franchement, moi, je préfère la bouffe. Si y'en a y préfèrent la musique et ben, c'est pas...
Merde ! J'dois faire quoi ?
Goatee, c'est quoi ? Goatee, c'est le GAME OF THE YEAR ! C'est le Game Of The Year ?
Ok, je fais le Game Of The Year, c'est le Goty. Game of The Year !
Voilà, c'est bon, j'ai fait le Game Of The Year! *se répète*
LE GOTY ! J'ai fait le GOTY !
Cette blague a duré beaucoup trop longtemps... *rire* Mais vous l'avez constaté ? Moi aussi hein...
Allez ! Une p'tite dernière ! Moi, j'veux le 6 sur 6 !
Et m'en aller tranquillement...
Un phare... un phare, c'est quoi ?
Ca fait comme ça, c'est au bord de l'eau.
Y'a la lumière, comme ça, qui fait ça, et voilàaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa...
Easy ! Une river *avec un accent anglais super*
*chante*
*rire* Oh les mecs! J'ai fait un trait, j'ai fait un trait, y me dit, c'est une rivière !
Non non, mais c'est quoi ça ?
Le DENTIFRICE ! Putain mec ! C'est incroyable...
Fork... fourchette... fourchette... C'est quoi une fourchette finalement ?
C'est juste un p'tit instrument comme ça avec des piques qui permettent d'attraper la nourriture.
Euh... de manière légale, voilà.
Une pool, une pool, on l'a d'jà fait, c'est hyper simple.
C'est "vue aérienne", n'oubliez pas. N'oubliez pas le drone du djihad.
Ok, on fait les zigzags dans la piscine et c'est une pool. Parfait...
Et voilà, 6 sur 6. C'est tout pour moi, on finit l'année en beauté.
Sur du gros dessin, de la bonne oeuvre d'art.
Vous avez senti la douille ?
C'est toi Inspecteur Bigoudi ?
Tu as compté le nombre de dessins que j'ai fait et tu t'es aperçu que j'en ai fait que 5 ?
*frappe sur ca chaise*  sal*perie de Bigoudi!
Effectivement, il fallait que je dessine un pot de peinture et il a pas trouvé...
Il a pris ça pour une théière...
Et voilà les gens, c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo, n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Bah voilà, on a fini l'année sur du bon dessin bien beau, comme on l'aime...
Hein... depuis... ça fait déjà 3 ans que vous êtes fan de mes oeuvres d'art et je vous remercie...
Je sais très bien que, si un jour, je sais plus dessiner, vous vous désabonnerez de la chaîne
parce qu'elle n'aura plus d'intérêt à vos yeux et... Je... Vous comprendrez, vous en faites pas...
Mais voilà, aujourd'hui encore, on a prouvé 6 sur 6.
Euh... ferme ta gueule, inspecteur Bigoudi.
Allez ! A la prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez vous bien, tchao tout le monde. LE PEACE !
*Jingle de fin*